this idea of Donald Trump being a
Russian asset dating all the way back to
the 1980s is getting more and more
attention and it's about to get even
more attention because a new book claims
the exact same thing and over the last I
guess week to ten days
Omarosa versus Trump has been getting a
lot of attention but that's sort of like
the pop culture story to this more
serious organized-crime Russian asset
story and there's a new book called
house of Trump house of Putin the untold
story of Donald Trump in the Russian
mafia and the author of the book is
Craig Unger who's a harvard-educated
investigative journalist who's done some
really great investigative work in the
past including the book house of Busch
House of Saud related to the bush
family's relationship with the royal
family of Saudi Arabia and this new book
trump house of Trump House of Putin
starts first of all by naming 59
specific Russians that Craig Unger
claims are business associates of Donald
Trump now remember Trump has claimed
many times to have no business with
Russians period aside from the
occasional luxury condo sale in
Manhattan or whatever else so that's one
part of this that fifty-nine specific
Russian individuals are named as having
relationships with Donald Trump but the
real story in the book is that Unger
claims that Trump may be compromised and
a Russian asset and specifically says
that the reason Trump may have become a
compromised Russian asset is that he has
allegedly been laundering billions of
dollars in Russian money through his
real estate deals with Russians and
these alleged financial ties with Russia
go obviously directly counter to what
Trump has specifically said before like
for example Trump said quote I have no
dealings with Russia
I have no deals that could happen in
Russia because we've stayed away and I
have no loans with Russia
I have no loans with Russia at all so
let's take a step back first of all why
would Russia have all this money that
they want to launder like why would
Russians be in positions to want to
launder money through Trump rather than
Nick
raagh ones for example well this all
dates back to when the Soviet Union
imploded and caused what's called
capital flight rich Russians had money
that they wanted to get out the Russian
mafia had money that they wanted to get
out and two really good ways to get
money out and then launder it are
casinos and real estate
Trump is involved in both of them
casinos are more conspicuous ways
because they are so well known as ways
to launder money so they apparently went
in the direction of real estate
now why would Trump do it right maybe
initially it was for the money when you
help launder money you get a cut when
Trump had financial troubles remember
Trump always brags about how he never
filed personal bankruptcy but his
businesses did for a while Trump was
having trouble getting loans the
money-laundering from the Russians may
have alleviated that financial situation
and then as very often happens he gets
in too deep and maybe he can't get out
and in his book Craig Unger has
interviewed Russian mafia Russian
government connected individuals and
what Unger can't say for sure is whether
Trump did all of this knowingly or
whether he was sort of taken advantage
of right he was the Patsy he was the
useful idiot it's not 100 percent clear
Unger was asked by Newsweek in an
article about the book whether he thinks
Russians have compromising personal
information about Trump this relates to
the steel dossier and Unger said he
doesn't even think if the PP tape exists
that it matters because once again Trump
claimed to have zero Russian business
associates and Unger found 59 and his
argument is the P tape may exist the P
tape may not exist but it really doesn't
matter because of these 59 Russian
contacts asked by Newsweek in this
interview Craig Unger was asked which of
your findings do you think Americans
would find most shocking he said he has
reason to believe here we go now that
there is a Russian asset in the White
House who Unger believes is not just
compromised by Russia but an actual
Russian agent that's not 100% clear and
at the those are very very big
allegations to me
but this is not a guy with a bad
reputation when it comes to
investigative journalism as a Hugh did
you say huge bird just random does that
last that was crazy that startled me Act
only we got that on camera yeah Birds
just unable to identify glass continues
to be a thing evolutionarily it doesn't
seem to be fading away so listen as far
as this book goes if only 5% of what's
in this book is true and again Unger has
a very good reputation this is the stuff
that history books will be writing about
if 20% of the book is true it's a
historic report I mean that I'm starting
to lack the vocabulary to properly
encapsulate how absurd this is it's it
sounds like the most extreme allegation
you can make in this whole Russia Trump
scandal that Trump is some Manchurian
Candidate who's being operated by the
Russians it sounds hyperbolic but yet he
has the contacts right he has those 59
names yes you can make a strong case and
you don't have to make the case that
it's a Manchurian Candidate per se you
can actually make the case that it's
sort of a bumbling fool who over the
last 35 years has one small step at a
time become compromised and that now
this is just sort of where he naturally
ended up and putting the actual Russians
aside for a second everyone who allows
Trump to avoid consequences for
everything he's done
like let's assume eventually we figure
out exactly what he's done if you allow
him to avoid consequences you are sort
of a de facto Russian asset in the sense
that legally if any of this stuff is
true when you allow it to have no
consequences you further the goals of
those who have allegedly compromised
Trump and you're actually starting to
get into RICO stuff
Rico is the Racketeer Influenced Corrupt
Organizations Act and this is a legal
legal framework at the federal level
that was signed into law by Richard
Nixon of all people in the 1970s and
what it says is that if you commit
crimes that are part of a broader
basically organized crime I mean it was
meant to fight organized crime that it
is much more serious legally speaking so
if you just launder money
you've laundered money okay if you
launder money as part of a money
laundering racketeering and extortion
organization
then it's falls under Rico and we have
here a president who may have willingly
or unwillingly participated in criminal
activity that would fall under Rico this
is not going away if anything it's
building and we're actually trying to
get Craig Unger on the program to try to
get him to talk about the book and the
research that he's done amazing what we
are learning learning every single week
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show and boy do we have a good
one for you today today's program is
made possible in part by zip recruiter
you've heard me tell stories about the
difficulties of hiring on the David
Pakman show before and hiring in general
can be very difficult all the different
job sites the stacks of resumes but it
can be a lot easier when you go to zip
recruiter dot-com slash Pakman with
their powerful matching technology zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards and it'll
also scan thousands of resumes in their
database to actually proactively find
people with the experience for the job
you've listed and get them to apply as
the applications come in zip recruiter
will analyze each spotlight the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match and it's so effective that 80% of
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the website
within the first day I think that in our
audience we have all sorts of different
business owners I know because they
contact me all the time many of them
have employees and the results really
speak for themselves and it's no wonder
that zip recruiter is the highest rated
hiring site in America and now my
listeners and viewers who were looking
to hire can try zip recruiter for free
at the exclusive web address zip
recruiter dot-com slash Pakman that's
zip recruiter dot-com slash PA k ma and
the smartest way to hire one more time
zip recruiter dot-com slash Pakman